the number one thing that I think could
change our game really fast is Community
Management the cool thing is I think
everybody should do it because it's the
quickest way to learn what's actually
happening here it's just like listening
is different than replying as we go more
Jetsons the people that act like The
Flintstones are going to win your
grandparents are more theoretically
prepared for social media than you are
because they invented coming over your
house and giving you a cake when your
grandmother died now you have technology
and you can scale that can we please
deploy some soul don't listen to
anything listen to your consumer not the
headlines just your consumer